100 milliarden euro für die ausrüstung
der bundeswehr
so lautete das versprechen des
bundeskanzlers ende februar kurz nach
dem überfall russlands auf die ukraine
scholz sprach von einer zeitenwende
bessere ausrüstung modernes einsatzgerät
mehr personal das kostet viel geld wir
werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und unsere
verteidigung investieren doch wie diese
ankündigungen genau zu verstehen sind
interpretieren die parteien jede für
sich offenbar anders
sicherheits ist mehr als alleine
investitionen in die bundeswehr wir sind
zum beispiel auch sehr anfällig gegen
cyberangriffe und diese spielen eine
rolle wie nie zuvor wir reden über
investitionen in die bundeswehr in die
streitkräfte das ist das was mit einem
sondervermögen sprich 100 milliarden
sondern schulden zu finanzieren ist
andere vorstellungen die bei ampel
ministern bestehen müssen aus dem
haushalt heraus finanziert werden die
spd sieht darin parteipolitische
spielchen
soweit ich weiß ist die bundeswehr in
fragen der cybersicherheit tätig also
insofern wäre geld für die bundeswehr
möglicherweise auch geld für die
cybersicherheit aber ganz klar ist wie
gesagt vereinbart ist ist ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr die
ampel ist auf die stimmen der union im
bundestag angewiesen denn für die
bereitstellung des sondervermögens
bedarf es einer grundgesetzänderung
gestern also erneut die suche nach einem
kompromiss
treffen der verhandlungsführer im
bundesfinanzministerium am ende aber
kein statement wie geplant man habe sich
aber geeinigt heißt es in einer
schriftlichen erklärung
notwendige maßnahmen zur cybersicherheit
zivilschutz sowie zur ertüchtigung und
stabilisierung von partnern werden aus
dem bundeshaushalt finanziert
die union hat sich mit ihrer forderung
offenbar durchgesetzt die
cybersicherheit aus dem sondervermögen
auszuklammern
die zeit drängt drei monate nachdem olaf
scholz eine zeitenwende ausgerufen hat
ist in deutschland immer noch kein
einziges neues rüstungsprojekt auf den
weg gebracht worden kritisiert die
opposition
und jetzt ist die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht bei uns im studio herzlich
willkommen guten morgen entscheiden
morgen wir wissen also es gab eine
einigung gestern abend die frage ist
jetzt die nach dem weiteren ablauf wird
das sommer sondervermögen vor der
sommerpause des bundestages im
grundgesetz verankert davon gehe ich
fest aus das kann sehr schnell jetzt
gelingen denn die wesentlichen punkte
sind vereinbar das muss jetzt umgesetzt
werden aber das ist möglich und das ist
auch wichtig ein ganz wichtiges zeichen
dass wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass die
bundeswehr endlich so ausgestattet wird
wie es notwendig ist damit wir die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
gewährleisten können das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen dass von gestern abend
ausgeht und jetzt geht es an die
umsetzung
wir hatten heute morgen schon alexander
dobrindt von der csu bei uns im studio
der eben auch noch mal gesagt es gibt
eine bestimmte liste so eine wirtschafts
listet wirtschaftsplan sie hatten jetzt
ja als verteidigungsministerin drei
monate zeit sich schon darauf
vorzubereiten was genau steht also auf
der liste drauf auf dieser liste haben
wir identifiziert was brauchen wir denn
um genau diese landes und
bündnisverteidigung in zukunft
sicherzustellen und da geht es wirklich
um die gesamte bandbreite der bundeswehr
das geht von nachtsichtgeräten das geht
funkgeräte es geht aber auch um schweren
transporthubschrauber es geht also
wirklich um die gesamte bandbreite
wir haben es sehr sehr wohl schon
gedanken gemacht das heißt wir können
jetzt auch loslegen wenn diese
sondervermögen zur verfügung steht es
kommt nämlich darauf an dass jetzt auch
ganz schnell all das organisiert wird
das die bundeswehr richtig aufgestellt
ich brauche allein um meine
verpflichtungen in der nato erfüllen zu
können für 20 milliarden munition das
muss jetzt also das sehen sie es ist die
gesamte bandbreite die in diesem
wirtschaftsplan abgedeckt also das
sondervermögen ist das eine und dann
eben dass zwei prozent ziel das andere
die für verteidigung jahr erreicht
werden soll das wird allerdings nicht im
grundgesetz verankert einfach weil das
bruttoinlandsprodukt bei der festsetzung
des haus landet eben noch nicht
feststeht jetzt sagt ihre
parteivorsitzende saskia esken dass
dieses zwei prozent ziel zitat nicht
jedes jahr gleichermaßen erreicht werden
können sie nochmal für klarheit sorgen
erreichen wir jetzt jedes jahr die 2
prozent oder nicht wir haben uns darauf
verständigt dass wir das in einem
anderen zeitraum betrachten das heißt
insgesamt muss pro jahr über einen
zeitraum von fünf jahren dieses 2
prozent 10 erfüllt werden weil wir
natürlich auch abhängig davon sind wie
schnell kann die industrie liefern wie
schnell können das was wir in auftrag
geben wie schnell kann das erfüllt
werden und deswegen muss es nicht pro
jahr aber in diesem gesamt zeitraum von
fünf jahren pro jahr dann erfüllt war
das kann mal mehr sein das kann mal
weniger sein aber das ist die zielgröße
dann sprechen wir auch über die
waffenlieferungen wir wissen der
ukrainische präsident wohl oder mir
selensky bittet ja täglich eigentlich um
schwere waffen die situation im donbass
für die ukrainische armee immer
aussichtsloser momentan muss man sagen
sie haben schon sieben panzerhaubitzen
2000 angekündigt und 15 gepard
flugabwehr panzer zugesagt warum ist
davon noch nichts angekommen ich war
gerade freitag dort wo die ukrainischen
soldaten ausgebildet werden an der
panzerhaubitze 2000 dass ein
hochmodernes gerät und da dauert die
ausbildung circa 40 tage dass es auch
mit der ukraine so vereinbart dass es
auch wichtig damit die soldaten nicht
zur zielscheibe werden damit sie auch
dann entsprechend kämpfen können und
diese zeit ist notwendig auch aus
verantwortung gegenüber den soldaten die
geparden müssen aufbereitet werden die
sind nämlich nicht in dem zustand dass
man sie einfach in die ukraine liefern
kann sondern auch da muss auch bereitet
muss ausgebildet weil es läufern alle
seine mängel ab dem der ort schon ein
basler geht alles in enger abstimmung
mit der ukraine aber uns ist es wichtig
in ybbs in abstimmung mit meinem
ukrainischen kollegen auch dass die
soldaten die damit kämpfen müssen dann
auch entsprechend ausgebildet indes weg
ist es uns so wichtig dass wir zum
beispiel auch mit unseren partnern
abstimmungen treffen das gerät das
schnell geliefert werden kann an dem
auch sofort gekämpft werden kann jetzt
beispielsweise aus tschechien dass das
abgegeben wird und wir dann auffüllen
deswegen wir arbeiten an verschiedenen
ebenen um die ukrainisch team
unterstützen natürlich verständlich wenn
wir uns trotzdem mal das angucken was
außerhalb von deutschland passiert
dänemark zum beispiel liefert
atomraketen italien anti panzer waffen
also andere nato länder sind da schon
weitaus aktiver und agnes strack
zimmermann von der fdp die vorsitzende
des bundes verteidigungsausschusses hat
getwittert deutschland vermittelt
inzwischen das bild des bremsers und
users das geht doch in ihre richtung das
aber auch ins bild dass ich nicht
wahrnehmen und dass ich vor allen dingen
auch nicht von den kollegen in europa
gespiegelt bekomme beispielsweise oder
auch in der nato wir sitzen ja
regelmäßig zum beispiel in einem
rammstein format zusammen tauschen und
austauschen uns aus stimmen uns ab und
wenn der denn der ukrainische kollege
der verteidigungsminister resnik ob
twittert dass er sich für die
konstruktive zusammenarbeit und für die
unterstützung ausdrücklich bei
deutschland bekannt dann ist das glaube
ich ein zeichen das nicht untergehen
trotzdem wissen sie es gibt kritik an
ihnen im amts der
bundesverteidigungsministerium friedrich
merz hat vor zwei wochen schon ihre
absetzung gefordert dann gab es
spekulationen über einen wechsel
möglicherweise auf einen anderen
kabinettsposten also wie angezählt
fühlen sie sich da ich habe eine große
aufgabe und die erfülle ich das wüsste
zum beispiel die umsetzung des 100
milliarden programms da geht es aber
auch um die unterstützung der ukraine
und es geht vor allen dingen auch in
dieser bundeswehr endlich das
beschaffungswesen zu reformieren da ist
richtig viel zu tun und das ist meine
aufgabe und sie kümmern sie haben auch
mitbekommen dass es verwirrung gab über
eine äußerung ihrer staatssekretärin
müller die hat vor kurzem bei uns im zdf
kundgetan es gebe eine nato absprache
keine schweren waffen an die ukraine zu
liefern haben sich viele schon
verwundert die augen gerieben und gesagt
ist uns gar nicht bekannt also war das
ein versprecher hatte sich der
verstolpert oder können sie da mal vor
aufklärung soll jedes land entscheidet
eigenständig welche waffen zu liefern
und wann diese waffen geliefert werden
aber wir stimmen uns immer in der nato
in der eu ab miteinander wer was liefert
und vielleicht auch in welchen
kooperation es laufen kann die
panzerhaubitzen beispielsweise werden
mit den niederländern ausgebildet die
soldaten und dann auch in einer feier
einheit von insgesamt 12 7 von uns fünf
von den niederlanden dann dorthin
gebracht wir haben die slowakei mit den
niederlanden sofort unterstützt als
diese ihr
luftverteidigungssystem an die ukraine
abgegeben haben sie mit patriot sind und
mit soldaten also bei uns ist das
wichtig als deutschland uns immer
abzustimmen keine deutschen alleingänge
sondern immer mit unseren partnern
zusammen zu agieren das ist uns sehr
wichtig und genauso agieren beim
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht war das bei uns im studio ganz
herzlichen dank für das interview